Airbnb transformed the travel industry
in less than 10 years it provides a
worldwide online platform to connect
guests with private room and home
rentals founded in 2008 the company is
now valued at more than 30 billion
dollars it features more than 3 million
listings around the world Airbnb is now
expanding to include online restaurant
reservations and local sightseeing
opportunity's called experiences the
company is announcing more than 150 new
experiences today in New York City Brian
Chesky is co-founder and CEO of Airbnb
Brian good morning thank you for having
me again so explain what experiences is
and how that essentially complements
your current business model we realized
that when people travel they want to
have a great experience and so we
realize what if we can power local
people including local New Yorkers to
share a two to three hour guided
activity from beekeeping on a roof to
horseback riding in Queens to a concert
in someone's living room basically if
you have a passion you could share with
another person and we think that when
you travel rather than just going to see
a site you could actually have a really
cool experience first of all who knew
there was horseback riding in my why
they're keeping so you weren't out you
weren't satisfied mr. Chesser hugely
successful company yeah well decided we
wanted to take it to the next level well
our company took us here so our
community did our community where we
have four million homes only millions of
hosts and they were offering their homes
but they started coming to and say we'd
like to offer more and we said well more
like what yeah
and they said well you know some people
said I would get people tour the city or
I'll make them dinner and before we knew
it their imaginations kind of showed us
a path forward so they provided all the
experiences in other words you didn't go
out seeking the experiences no no
primarily people just came to us we have
tens of thousands of people who came to
us and applied and said we want to offer
experiences for people somebody might be
a cook and they say I wanna be able to
create food in someone's home we have a
guy named Dave in Seattle and he has a
wolf conservation and he said I would
like to give people a tour of a woods
and I have these wolves and you can hike
with the wolves well dave is now making
$200,000 a year hiking with wolves so
this is actually an amazing opportunity
for economically
fascinating that people came to you and
said we want to do more yes when I did
air B&B in st. Barts
the owner had left champagne and leopard
all these instructions and I was amazed
by their house of hospitality for total
strangers I think they're our community
kind of proved a lot of people wrong
that people are fundamentally really
really kind because we have this idea
people said this will never work
strangers will never stay in another
changes home and I totally get why
people said that but 200 million people
later I think it's pretty clear that
people not only want to connect with
others they want to share more than just
their home they want to share great
experiences let's talk about the
expansion of B&B Airbnb how are you
doing in China how are you doing in
terms of international expansion that
China's going really well we are as far
as we can tell the largest home sharing
company in all of China and we have
nearly a hundred thousand homes in China
and we've had millions of people in
China use Airbnb all over the world
competitors we have a couple Chinese
competitors I know how difficult as you
know yeah I think it was a little
absolutely and a lot of American
companies have struggled in China I
think one difference in Airbnb is work
travel company and so if a person who
china wants to travel around the world
they want to stay in home in Paris
they're not going to use a Chinese
website and so you would call an
international network affect our global
community has given us I think a leg up
you know Brian seem to be on top of
things there was a big car not not big
controversy but a little kerfuffle about
Airbnb while black hired Eric Holder to
look in Justin and then when white
supremacist wanted to rent their
Apartments you stepped you stepped in
about that talk about that from your
point of view what you're trying to do
well about a year and a half ago we
started noticing discrimination on our
platform and this is something that is
in opposition of our mission it you know
our platform only works and people
accept each other so we hired Eric
Holder and he helped us create a
non-discrimination policy and now when
you sign up for Airbnb you have to sign
a community commitment that says that
you will not discriminate against people
including allowing people of all
backgrounds in your home we notice that
white nationalist we're attempting to
use our site for one of the major
rallies and we prevented them from using
our site and of course that created some
backlash from those groups but you
obviously have to stand up for what you
another reason why your mom and dad who
are here today because your mom said
what she was telling me that they
thought it was off the wall when they
heard this phrasing you for the guts to
do it
they thought you're going to work in art
and here you are Here I am Congrats to
you thank you very much thank you
Brian Chesky always good to have you at
the table